me voy a permitir
por ser el que cierra
intervenciones todas extraordinarias y
estimulantes
es decir que en efecto hemos podido
comprobar que se han cumplido objetivos
como
la interdisciplinaria
de profesiones distintas
de hombres y mujeres inteligentes
pero quería decir que también es muy
interesante que
nos hemos reunido jóvenes y mayores
y eso es importante
el diálogo la colaboración
intergeneracional es otro de los
desafíos que tiene en este momento la
sociedad porque tenemos aún la idea de
que la ciudad de las edades son unos
pasos por unos tramos no son formas de
habitar en territorios distintos la edad
son territorios por tanto el poder
colaborar entre esos territorios es otra
de las cosas que
momentos tenemos como desee
así que quería aprovechar ya que soy el
de más edad y que curiosamente voy a
hablar del futuro
labrador
y gracias porque para mí es un placer
y un estímulo el que me escucháis
durante unos minutos que os voy a hablar
de
las utopías
hablar de las de las de las utopías pero
las utopías no son ensoñaciones no
decimos cuando alguien nos presenta una
cosa sí sí es muy interesante
pero decimos pero es utópico una forma
suave de decir que es irrealizable y no
guardamos también en nosotros esa
sospecha de que la utopía es engaño
y si fuera todo lo contrario si la
utopía hoy fuera una necesidad una
necesidad para salir del presente una
necesidad para rebelarse contra aquellos
que nos dicen
que el presente suficiente
y los valores
los modelos del sistema son
incuestionables que en todo caso eso sí
se pueden retocar
a mejorarlos para amplificar los
pero donde estén las certezas donde
estén las certezas que nos preserva con
ese cobijo de la intemperie de la
incertidumbre que por favor no lo
renovamos y es que las utopías se llevan
mal con el poder porque porque las
utopías arrancan de una disconformidad
con el presente
una crítica un análisis crítico del
presente pero para que esa
disconformidad no se convierta en
frustración la utopía aporta además
imaginación creación de escenarios
posibles posibles y sí por qué no
escenarios posibles que permitan decir
hoy estamos aquí
en esta ventanilla del tren y me estás
diciendo que hemos llegado a la estación
terminal pero si esto es un apeadero
porque te empeñas en decirnos que ya
hemos llegado esa rebeldía es la clave
de la utopía pero hay que añadir otra
cosa también muy importante la utopía es
seducción tiene que ser seductora porque
porque hay que remover el valle de la
cotidianidad
pero para entrar en el papel que tienen
las utopías en el presente quiero que
nos fijemos en algo que aunque es
habitual a lo mejor no le prestan le
prestamos especial atención cierto que
todos aceptamos que nos situamos en el
espacio pero también nos situamos en el
tiempo como quiero haceros ver nos
situamos en el espacio y decimos allí
por allí sale el sol por ahí se pone
pero también en el tiempo decimos
ahí está el pasado
está el futuro y aquí
está mi lugar en el tiempo el presente
pero lo curioso es que durante
prácticamente toda nuestra existencia
como humanos en esta línea del tiempo
nos hemos colocado así fijaos
así
mirando el pasado
porque en el pasado estaba todo dicho
ahí estaban los héroes y sus hazañas que
teníamos que imitar ahí estaban las
divinidades con sus revelaciones ahí
estaban los monarcas bienhechores y ahí
también los sabios con sus inventos todo
eso lo teníamos que recoger e intentar
en lo posible replicarlo instalarlo en
nuestro lugar en el tiempo en el
presente y como naturalmente somos
imperfectos nunca conseguíamos hacer una
copia una reproducción exacta de ese
áureo e imitable pasado así que generaba
permanentemente esa sensación que
arrastrado el ser humano de culpabilidad
por no estar
bien el pasado aquí el presente
y dónde está el futuro
a nuestra espalda es decir no lo vemos
en esta posición y ya sabemos que todo
aquello que no vemos nos produce temor
que todo lo malo llega sin verlo
así que para esta posición prácticamente
durante toda nuestra existencia el
futuro el futuro era el fin de los
tiempos el futuro era por venir pero
cuando venía se acababa el tiempo se
acababa la concepto que teníamos de ese
tiempo así que os dais cuenta la
cantidad de culturas que han
interpretado esta forma de situarnos en
el tiempo y por tanto del futuro como
porvenir
el fin de los tiempos una catástrofe en
muchos casos purificadora de este género
humano
el futuro como advenimiento
pues bien
muy recientemente muy recientemente
y hemos empezado
es un trascendental bueno recientemente
unos 500 años que no es nada para la
vida humana y hemos empezado a hacer un
giro
zen dental que ha sido este que estoy
haciendo yo ahora
es decir ir dejando atrás el pasado el
pasado queda atrás y enfrentarte con qué
con la niebla del futuro así que frente
a ese esplendoroso pasado que había que
imitar ahora ahora los humanos nos
encontramos con un futuro neblinoso tan
neblinoso
que es la niebla más densa e inquietante
que tiene el ser humano que cuál es la
niebla de la incertidumbre es tal en el
efecto que nos produce que ahora todos
los humanos
tenemos tortícolis
no podemos dejar mirar atrás hay ese
pasado ese es pasado añorado porque esto
es impresionante por eso cuando nos
encontramos con esa niebla aparecen las
clásicas utopías que todos conocemos es
la de tomás moro la de francis bacon la
de tomás o campanela que que nos decían
todas ellas nos decían detrás de la
niebla está el futuro
el futuro es un lugar por eso todas las
utopías clásicas las utopías son una
ciudad esplendorosa
una isla y os dais cuenta que toda la
estructura narrativa consiste en que
alguien ha llegado allí la ha
descubierto y vuelve a contárnoslo para
emocionarnos y afectar el riesgo del
extravío atravesar la niebla y alcanzar
el futuro
pues eso ha llegado esa forma de
entender el futuro ha llegado hasta
finales del 19 el concepto de progreso
tan decimonónicos esa idea el futuro
está lo que hay que hacer es progresar
para alcanzarlo
pero en el 21 no ahora todos nosotros no
vemos esto así
que estamos ante la niebla del futuro
pero detrás de la niebla
detrás de la niebla no hay más que
niebla
así que no hay que atravesarla como esos
navegantes de la época que era la que
inspiraba estas utopías que descubrían
territorios no hay que atravesarla hay
que desplazarla y se desplazan
construyendo así que nos estamos
encontrando los contemporáneos ya no el
futuro como porvenir ya no el futuro por
llegar por por alcanzarlo sino el futuro
por hacer
una zozobra pensad que el futuro está en
nuestras manos y si esta forma de ver el
tiempo nos generaba culpabilidad
esta forma de ver el tiempo
genera
sensación inmensa de responsabilidad
por eso ahora nos gustan más a los
contemporáneos que nos metan miedo y eso
se llama distopías
y nos gusta escuchar las distopías como
les gusta a los niños que les cuenten
historias de miedo cuando se van a
dormir eso si te la escuchan con la
sábana tapando la pues eso hacemos los
humanos nos gustan las series de black
mirror porque porque nos están con ese
miedo confirmando nuestros temores
pero qué diferencia hay entre utopía y
distopía cierto las dos las dos son
críticas con el presente es tan
disconforme con el presente pero fijaos
qué estrategia más distinta de crear el
escenario motivador
presenta un escenario vertiginoso es
decir te aproxima a un precipicio y te
dice
si seguimos como estamos en el presente
ahí tienes el vértigo del precipicio
eso está bien
pero produce algo preocupante y es que
ese vértigo te puede producir temor y
encogimiento en cambio la utopía te dice
te das cuenta que si conseguimos saber
salir del presente nos encontramos con
la emergencia de un potencial que
llevamos los humanos ese es el escenario
posible que podemos alcanzar es la
diferencia
y apuesto por eso porque apuesto por eso
porque llevamos 3.500 millones de años
demostrando que la estrategia principal
la evolución somos nosotros también
evolución ha consistido en poder
soportar el efecto destructor de la
incertidumbre
generar muchas formas y funciones
distintas para que sea tan incontrolable
siempre tenga una respuesta por parte de
la vida con una forma adecuada
funcionando también que aquí estamos
nosotros que somos producto de la
evolución pero le devolvemos a esta
evolución que nos ha colocado en el
universo les devolvemos el favor y se lo
devolvemos extraordinariamente porque
porque aportamos este cerebro aporta
estrategia nueva
ya no solo la de la diversidad sino la
capacidad de prever
de prever de imaginar un futuro no
esperaba que la incertidumbre llegue
sino intentar prever y construir un
futuro
eso es impresionante y lo venimos
haciendo como humanos desde el primer
momento que tomamos un canto rodado
formas redondas y como preveíamos como
imaginábamos nuestra mano era conducida
por la imagen que queríamos alcanzar y
golpeábamos así consecuentemente la
piedra y salía el bifaz y salía el hacha
de piedra pues desde ese primer golpe
hasta este mundo que hemos construido lo
hemos hecho porque lo hemos imaginado
así que por favor como en este momento
de encrucijada no reaccionamos como no
apostamos por la imaginación
la disconformidad crítica y la capacidad
cervera nosotros lo que nos podemos
construir nosotros con nuestras propias
manos
y solamente deciros por favor
por favor educación liberar las formas
que impide que este impulso natural de
crear que tiene el cerebro sea o ven con
las normas que ahora todos
muchísimas gracias muy amable
muchas gracias
muy amable
a construir todos utopías
y sobre todo enseñárselo a los jóvenes